creatively I think it's better and I
think the one thing that I I like most
about making live content
um and I maybe you guys are starting to
appreciate this more is that when you're
done you turn the stream off you're done
yeah that's it it's over I mean that's
just me doing trash taste and every
other kind of content I have grown very
jealous for you guys to be able to like
turn on my camera uh go like go to a
film session and uh like having like a
block in your calendar that is like okay
after after the calendar after the
camera's off I'm done yeah I mean
there's that obviously but I I was
really getting tired of the
post-production aspect of it oh yeah and
having to deal with
if we filmed somewhere you know maybe
they want to have a look at the video
and they want to change a ton of things
that are really mind you and don't
matter but they care about it for some
reason yeah and then you know you're
like okay well that's why I don't do
videos that warranty yeah bro like it's
tough I you know I feel that I was just
getting really burnt out with the
post-production in Japan and having to
go through the videos yeah and make them
good and I just didn't have a talent for
it like I would talk to Chris and
Christian Science be like man that video
was bad and I was like I know it's bad
but I don't know how to [__] to make it
better I'm [__] at this I this video was
tough and I think I would need to be
better at what I do and I think I've
gotten a lot better now but yeah I was
really like not good at it for a very
long time and I still think I'm good but
I'm getting better and I just don't
enjoy it as much as I just I get so much
more excited about an idea when it's
live yeah so I I just kind of lean
towards that now yeah I mean your
personality is definitely like garnered
towards that like for me I really really
[__] missed scripted content after
I've been doing like live streams and
like second Channel and trash days and
stuff you can tell such stories yeah but
then I'm like I sit down and like I what
I don't miss is waking up some days and
I'm like I'm gonna get x amount of words
done in my scripts and you wake up and
you get the sentence done and you're
like
[__] today was a write-off you know
today today was right off right because
like some days you wake up and you're
like I am writing like a [__] machine
and sometimes you wake up and you're
like I cannot think of anything that's
what I like about streaming right like
even if it's like that's what I like
about it as well I'll do a 13-hour
stream and I'll be like [__] I went
through the [__] Gauntlet but at
least I could have like I didn't [__]
procrastinate a day away yeah which I
easily could do when I was a YouTuber
mainly yeah you know because the one
benefit I liked is that I used to upload
weekly but I used to be able to make
all right I used to be able to make like
a month worth of videos and like I
really wanted to I could make it like a
week and a half oh no like some serious
grinding yeah then I kind of disappear
and no one knew yeah I kind of like that
but also I realized that I was also
creatively I was not improving as a
Creator because I wasn't taking that
time to really focus on how to uh
improve my content and how to become a
better Creator yeah like I've definitely
felt that with my second Channel where
I'm like I am a month and a half ahead
and I've done that just by being live
and I'm like it feels good to be to shut
off the stream and be like my job is
done but then I kind of miss I I cried
for a long time I've missed the scripted
content and I was like making different
kinds of content and I'm like I can do
this for a certain amount of time
after a while I'm like my mind goes to
like mush and I'm like I can't do it
well every year I get a head a little
bit on the second Channel yeah I
normally stream more than I
would do and I like to stream content
stuff and we get ahead on the second
Channel I'll make moon
December
load every day every other day I was
like are you sure I'm like let's do it
let's get the ad rev let's re-upload and
because you know I also want you know
it's a lot of work but I also yeah uh I
want because we we share the money so I
wanted I want to move down to this boys
to get paid well as well I was like
let's just go ham in December let's go
crazy then we end up in January with
like one video he's like oh Connor um we
need more videos right now and I'm like
oh I'm away for two weeks I'm like ah
I'll think of something it was
scrambling but it's nice because you're
never too far behind the videos well I
gotta asked
how did you guys learn how to like
manage people
because like I've I've realized like
because I work closely with my editor
Adam and a lot of other people like my
my like corporate experience was like so
[__] valuable for me to be like okay
there's a structured like system to like
manage someone and yeah kind of like I
communicate I think for me because I've
hired a lot of people now doing bearish
stuff
um
I think I think we're at that point now
with work in general where
I know what I need to what I need them
to do for it to make sense for me to
keep hiring them yeah right so I have a
set amount of things I need them to do
and if they do it I don't give a [__] if
they slack off for 10 hours or they
don't work one week yeah as long as in
that month everything I care about that
gets done gets done yeah and so you know
I I'm just Frank with that I I tell a
lot of my employees that I work with I'm
like hey I don't give a [__] what you do
as long as what I ask you to do gets
done and I'll never be anti-japanese
sentiment
hey you can bless the center you can go
and play TFT or OSU for 12 hours a day
yeah as long as in those you you cram in
those four hours and you get the thing
done and it's done well yeah
um and so I'm I'm pretty chill like I'm
I whether it's a good or a bad thing I I
don't know I think it works well with
some people it doesn't work well with
others yeah because I I can't be there
to like I don't have a manager who's
working with me it's just me I hire
people and I work with them because I
like to have that relationship
um but I I I'm I don't have the ability
to be Hands-On every single day and I'm
not going to have a meeting every week
like I'm just like I'll leave you to it
you do your thing here's what I'm going
to ask for and I'll keep spamming you
about stuff yeah uh and yeah and then it
normally works out and I think just
having that kind of relationship where
you both trust each other is very
important takes a while to get there but
once you get it it's invaluable like
that's worth more than anything I think
yeah in terms of you know it's like hey
I got you you got me uh we're good
totally agree yeah yeah I mean you
started you were a [__] company man
look at you CEO Nancy big boy big boy I
I probably sound really condescending
right now what a widow baby boy
baby boys
being adult is realizing you need help
and what that means uh figuring out how
to integrate that yeah I think I think
for me like doing the whole like
clothing company thing like I think I
got very lucky with people who I'm
surrounded with in terms of like the
company because like I I think it's a
matter of like okay no no I was about to
say like I'm an idiot I should interrupt
you mid-center like a [__] toddler
because I haven't thought carry on I I
think it's this whole idea of like I got
very blessed with having hired and
meeting people who are now responsible
for the company who are just way more
competent than I am well you know who
are like who are like just on top of
this [__] very professional like they're
still like you know I think you hire
good people and you figure out the job
afterwards absolutely like I think it's
a matter of like you know I think it's
it's all about like can do you have the
pulling power to be able to hire people
who are more competent than you I think
that's like the best you're not
competent dude compared to my like
dude I had nonsense for example my brand
manager and my head designer infinitely
more competent than I am like I I would
just straight up admit that like they
those guys are like everything good
you're seeing out of the nonsense right
now is because of those guys what's the
end goal with nonsense what are you what
are you feeling about end goal is to
just be able to like do you must have
had a vision when you started it right
yeah I mean obviously for me it's just
like you know I'm like my end goal with
nonsense is to get to the point where I
could be walking the streets of wherever
the [__] I am and I will see someone who
walks past me shirt and they don't know
who I am why why is that what you want
because because it's
it's
I'm going 80s mode I was just like I
would like to walk the streets of
anywhere and I was like North Korea
but I want
you because like I've been so I guess
like weirdly reliant on like the whole
anime man brand at this point that like
you know as of right now there's a
mixture of one of the branch out but
also have more of a long lasting effect
exactly like I want to get to the point
where like obviously right now because
you know our company is like just a year
old at this point right like we started
in June last year I feel like it's like
two three yeah we only started June last
year right like and so it's a very young
company and obviously the majority of
the people who are buying my clothes are
people who know me or like no trash at
the point where it's not that yeah I
want to get to the point where it's just
like people who just think the clothes
are [__] cool and I want to wear
those clothes regardless of who it comes
from or what the origins are can wear it
and just get to the point where like
again I could be walking the streets of
anywhere in the world I see someone
wearing an awesome t-shirt and they no
[__] idea who I am I think that's the
point like I just want to make cool [__]
regardless of where I currently
um socialist standing right like so and
you know obviously like I also want to
like you know just like make cool [__]
through that company regardless of what
it is
um because I've always had that like you
know dream to do so but like as of right
now at least my short-term goal is to
just like kind of expand the brand out
to the point where you don't necessarily
have to be a fan of me to be able to buy
my clothes yeah yeah and you know that's
very difficult right now obviously you
know kind of branching out from where
you currently are to a wider audience
but we're doing our best to try and get
to that point and hopefully next couple
of years we'll get to that point yeah
you know yeah why do you sound like
jumping yeah yes sorry I was trying to
sorry what what did you interrupt me on
I was like what's the goal what's the
end goal with nonsense how long do you
think trash days is Gonna Last oh
wow we're getting to that point yeah
we're getting that point three three
balls of wine in why not
just say what do you get okay what do
you think the end of trash taste looks
like what do you what I think the end of
trash Chase looks like I think it's one
of us get moving on you think it's we
all agree
you have a kid yeah you don't but you
the kid needs money gone you've got to
be here every goddamn way output okay
okay okay
I say that in like half Jess because I'm
like to me like the big kind of like
turning point for me yeah is I don't
think I'm gonna stop being friends with
you guys after I have a kiss but I'm
like okay guys
[__] you I'm done I have a priority now
and it's not you guys but like when I
have a kid that's like to me that's like
a commitment you know I I wanna
notice anymore okay so you're gonna come
to work everywhere so like that you you
must have gone my question being like
how long do you see yourself in Japan uh
yeah yeah how long do you see yourself
in Japan and to me that kind of like
the crossroads so yes I think at the
moment I think any of us leave Japan
it's going to be I imagine there'll be a
conversation like yeah yeah how do we
keep it going and then yeah like is it
worth continuing how do we end it hold
that thought because I got to piss okay
well we just keep talking yeah we'll
just see you talking keep talking yeah
because like I think it's valid I think
that's it I think you know I think
pretending like trash taste is going to
be a forever thing is dumb yeah and I
think thinking about it is wise yeah I
mean like trash trust Chase is like a
great thing a fun thing
um like I'm not like I said every show's
got to end yeah let's show except Grace
[__] anatomy and Law and Order which
will never end but at least I wanna I
wanna end on a bang I don't want to
whimper into like a [__] is that the
potaku shot of you talking no I wanted
potsaku to get even [__] bigger and I
could have which is which it could have
and I will stick by that to this day but
it's great because I have trash taste
now but like like less people to split
the [__]
[Laughter]
I just want to make I just wanted to
make something cool but like no to me
like kid when I have a kid they are
going to be top priority I want them to
have you're not going to want to yeah
you know you know ideally oh we're
[__] yeah yeah yeah and as as
relationship Japan is yeah as they
should be there there's enough people in
the world that have a kid and treat them
like a toy or like even like a pet like
they they treat like a pet like more
like a toy than like a commitment to
like raise this kid right and I'm like I
don't want to be that parent
um so you know that's like to me when I
decide to have a kid that's going to be
like the commitment uh whether I want to
settle down in Japan where I think Japan
is the best place to raise the kid I'm
still like up in the air about but like
they are going to take top priority yeah
I guess that's the question I have for
you too because like I think in my mind
I have a pretty you're gonna be here
forever I'm probably gonna be here are
you Japanese though Joe yeah
you know like if if you know gaijin's
been here for like decades has proven
anything like it's not impossible for
like complete foreigners to be here for
the rest of our life it's all about a
mentality my ideal scenario is that I've
got an insane boatload of cash and I can
live between the two countries to my
Will Wait UK and Japan yeah like I I I
can't ever see myself that's one
question I wanted to know is that like
to you guys what I I would love to have
that thing of like I fancy being in you
know maybe I live in the UK but I'm like
yeah I fancy two months in Japan I go to
my [__] Mansion I have in Japan I
order Sebastian to come over and clean
the dust because I haven't been here in
six months but you know the ideal is
that yeah I'd have I wouldn't have to
care about my having a [__] house in
there like I just live between the two
like that's uh but obviously that's a
stupid amount of money and time and
whatever but you know because I think
even if I leave Japan I think there'll
be a part of me that loves Japan dearly
I will want to be here every